BESMIRCHED.
THOSE OF THE POLICIES THAT
IMPROVE PEOPLE'S LIVES.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE NOT YOUR
AVERAGE TV PERSON.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
THIS IS AMAZING, KANYE TWITTER
ARTICULATED HIS SUPPORT FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
ONE OF HIS TWEETS, HE'S STILL
TWEETING.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO AGREE WITH
TRUMP COME UP WITH THE MOB
CANNOT MAKE ME NOT LOVE HIM.
WE ARE BOTH DRAGON ENERGY, HE IS
MY BROTHER.
I LIVE EVERYONE, I DON'T AGREE
WITH EVERYTHING ANYONE DOES.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES US
INDIVIDUALS.
WE HAVE A RIGHT TO INDEPENDENT
THOUGHT.
THE PRESIDENT RESPOND TO THIS BY
TWEETING THANK YOU, VERY COOL.
AFTER THE TWEETS, HIS TWITTER
FOLLOWING A PLUNGED, I THINK
THIS IS RIGHT, BY MORE THAN
9 MILLION FOLLOWERS.
JASON WE LIKE IS AN ANCHOR WITH
A FOX SPORTS OHIO ONE AND HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
I'M NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT KANYE WEST
DECIDED THAT HE IS ALLOWED AS A
CITIZEN OF A FREE COUNTRY TO SAY
WHAT HE WANTS TO SAY.
WHAT YOU ARE ON THIS?
>> I THINK HE WROTE IT BECAUSE
IT'S WHAT HE AUTHENTICALLY
BELIEVES AND I THINK HE IS
PROBABLY TRYING TO INSPIRE
AFRICAN-AMERICANS TO HAVE A MORE
OPEN MIND ABOUT POLITICS AND TO
BE LESS DEMONIZING POLITICS.
I THINK HE'S BEING TRUE TO
HIMSELF AND TRYING TO OPEN
AFRICAN-AMERICANS MINDS THAT IN
ALL THINGS, COMPETITION IS GOOD.
MY BACKGROUND IS FORCED AND
COMPETITION IS WHAT TAKES YOU TO
AN ENTIRE LEVEL.
THERE'S NO COMPETITION FOR THE
BLACK VOTE RIGHT NOW.
THERE HAS BEEN ON FOR 50 OR 60
YEARS.
I THINK WE SHOULD LOOK AROUND AS
OTHER ETHNIC GROUPS AND GROUPS
OF PEOPLE.
THEY MAKE PEOPLE CAN PETE FOR
THEIR VOTE AND POLITICS TEND TO
HELP THEM AND MOVE THEM FORWARD
WHILE WE ARE NOT THE SAME THING.
>> Tucker: ANY GROUP THAT
FEELS UNDER ATTACK CAN RETREAT
YOU SEE THIS AND OTHER GROUPS,
BUT I AGREE IT'S NOT HELPFUL.
WHAT'S THE RISK THAT YOU RUN IN
SAYING THIS?
EVEN FOR A FAMOUS GUY LIKE
KANYE WEST, IT SEEMS LIKE
POSITION TO TAKE.
WILL HE NOT BE PUNISHED FOR
THIS?
>> HE'S GOING TO BE PUNISHED
OVER SOCIAL MEDIA AND IT DOES
NOT SURPRISE ME THAT HE HAS LOST
A BUNCH OF TWITTER FOLLOWERS.
MONTHS OF SOCIAL MEDIA IS RIGGED
AND IF YOU STRAY PARTICULARLY AS
AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN FROM THE
TALKING POINTS THAT THE FAR LEFT
WING SIDE WANTS YOU TO COME OUT
THERE GOING TO ATTRACT -- HE'S A
FREETHINKER, HE ALWAYS HAS BEEN.
HIS MUSIC HAS ALWAYS BEEN OPEN
TO A LOT OF DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATION AND IDEAS.
HE'S BEING CONSISTENT AND TRUE
TO HIMSELF AND TRYING TO INSPIRE
PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: HE DIDN'T LOSE
9 MILLION FOLLOWERS, APPARENTLY
I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT, BUT YOU
ARE HEARING PEOPLE SAY HE MUST
HAVE A MENTAL ILLNESS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT
EXPLANATION?
>> I THINK IT'S RIDICULOUS AND
AGAIN, IT GOES TO US AS
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND SOCIAL
MEDIA HAS SO CONVINCED US THAT
LIBERAL MEANS FULL BLACK AND
CONSERVATIVE MEANS ANTIBLACK AND
THAT'S HOW WE INTERPRET THINGS.
HE HAS SAID THINGS THAT ARE
CONSERVATIVE OR ANY CONSERVATIVE
VALUES THAT HE IS EXPRESSED
SUPPORT FOR CANDACE OWENS OVER
SOCIAL MEDIA AND WE'VE BEEN
TRAINED THAT THAT MEANS
ANTIBLACK.
AGAIN, IF WE JUST LOOK
CRITICALLY, THAT'S JUST NOT THE
CASE.
MARTIN LUTHER KING WAS A VERY
CONSERVATIVE WITH HIS VALUES.
THE ENTIRE MOVEMENT WAS VERY
CONSERVATIVE, BUT SOMEHOW WE
CHANGED THAT AND YOU WOULD THINK
IT WAS THE MOST FAR LEFT WING
MOVEMENT IN THE WORLD AND THAT'S
HOW THEY GOT HERE FROM
LIBERALISM.
AGAIN, I'M NOT A POLITICAL
PARTISAN.
I DON'T PRETEND TO BE.
I'M A JOURNALIST AND AN
OBSERVER.
OBSERVING AND SPEAKING AS A
JOURNALIST AND NOT AN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN, OUR STRATEGY
IS FLAWED BY JUST GIVING AWAY
OUR ALLEGIANCE TO ONE SIDE.
I THINK KANYE OUT OF CONCERN FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS IS TRYING TO